let's crack open the honest trailer
vault from the guy who made a lien and
Blade Runner
brother comes of military recruitment
tool disguised as a gay romance
disguised as an action movie Top Gun
Code for America is on the razor's edge
of Armageddon now America's best pilots
will be pulled from active duty to trake
screw and play drawn-out games of
homoerotic beach volleyball
Oh and occasionally fighter planes the
kid from risky business is all grown up
and starring in a film with everything
you love about present-day America big
hair cool mustaches aviator shades and
sweet-ass jets hell yeah let's go kiss
some dudes I mean kiss some ass hi I
mean buy some planes yeah that's what
I'm then watch big egos collide at Top
Gun Academy their spice man who's cool
as ice maverick who plays by his own
rules goose because he flies and sundown
who's black ride along with these air
jockeys as they learn crucial tricks of
the trade like searching for missile
lock apart from missile lock
airplane mumbo-jumbo musical theater
watch Tom Cruise seduce America with an
adorable little smile that never leaves
his face no matter what situation he's
in witness the filmmakers pull out every
trick in the book
to make this five-foot-seven actor look
as tall as his co-stars by having them
lean sit lie down walk behind him or
just stick Tom up on an apple great must
have been someone else
meet the tough talking Charlie Blackwood
she's not just another sexy blonde broad
this sexy blonde broad knows stuff about
airplanes you were in a 4G inverted dive
with a mig-28 cheer has this no-nonsense
shoulder pad wearing ballbreaker gives
up on her career to make hot steamy love
to maverick that's a lot of ton then
crank up the homosexual undertones as
every other dude in the movie tries to
make hot steamy love to each other I
like to bust your butt but I can't
carnal knowledge of a lady this time
get the heart off don't tase me you
could be my wingman anytime I am
dangerous so suit up for an awesome
movie full of quotable lines
first
and a soundtrack so heavy it plays
danger zone three separate times
America yeah starring that Amish girl
who showed her boobs and witness some
girl that nerd from the Nerds movie
discount Burt Reynolds Nick rivers and
about Catholic Tom Cruise Tom Gunn so
this movie ends with him starting World
War three right be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers I don't want your
future fatality drink up let's boo-boo
oh no because of their Halsman crushed
cheese disappointed